[Music]
small you don't want to
another M dos I hear all the room don't
want to hear no more no more from you
start with a small do won't you I don't
want e the
nightmare sh memory talks I hear it
around the room don't want to hear no
more no more from you and you longer
seem to
C with what you ask for
but if you hav't
g well how can you start
again
I'm
I does it show more
I unless
[Music]
know no want to
be sh memory talks I hear around the
room don't want to hear no more no more
from
[Music]
you it's not enough to craw back because
you have to
realize that if you CH to start again
you're going to leave me
[Music]
me you no seem to
cold with what you as for and you no
longer seem to
cold with what you ask for so stop with
a small talk oh you don't want to Fe the
night you sh memory talks I hear it
around the roof don't want to hear no
more hear no more from you to stop with
a small talk W you I don't want to
Healing
night Shar memory talks I hear it around
the room don't want to hear no more hear
no more from you and you no longer seem
to
cope with what you ask for and you no
longer seem to
C with what you ask for
[Music]
you
are
[Music]
you
I doesn't show
[Music]
down
I'm Do It
show I
[Music]
Does it show the more
I know
[Music]